NARRATOR: 40 miles off the
coast of South Australia, shark
scientist Doctor Charlie
Huveneers and PhD student
Madeline Riley
investigate the best
way to fend off a shark attack.
The answer may be to prevent
it in the first place.
And then we just
need a few base ready.
And you're good to go.
All right, sounds good.
Let's hope the
sharks stick around.
You first!
NARRATOR: Their theory, that
the sharks ampulae of Lorenzini
can be used against it.
[music playing]
They're testing a new shark
deterrent that does just that.
So sharks are
capable of detecting
minute electric fields.
And the idea of this
electric deterrent
is to transmit a very
strong electric field that
will overwhelm that
sense of the shark,
so that as the shark
gets too close,
it's kind of nearly receiving
a punch in the face.
And the shark just
basically deterred.
NARRATOR: There's a lot
riding on this test.
Most shark deterrents
are designed
to protect just one person.
This one, which has been
tested for two years,
is much more ambitious.
[music playing]
If all goes well, it'll be
powerful enough to keep sharks
out of a section of
the ocean 25 feet
in diameter by 50 feet deep
without harming any swimmers.
That's bigger than
most swimming pools.
How it works is this big,
white thing is a float.
It just floats on
top of the water.
This black module is where
the power comes from.
And then underneath, we've got
a 4-meter long electrode, which
actually emits the
electric field, which
theoretically deters a shark.
[music playing]
NARRATOR: The first
thing they'll need
to test the deterrent, sharks.
Within moments, a 13-foot
great white turns up.
All right, we've got a
shark coming in at the back.
NARRATOR: And seems
curious about the device.
A large piece of bait
hangs near the electrode.
If the shark's
hungry, it'll have
to fight through the
electric field to get to it.
The team will film the shark's
reaction then analyze it after.
The shark circles, clearly
intrigued by the tasty morsel
floating in the ocean.
Coming back around.
NARRATOR: Scientists
monitor the action
as best they can from the deck.
They know that the entire
test is riding on this moment.
Investigators wait to
see if the great white
will break through the
constant electric current.
The shark gets closer
and closer with each pass
but doesn't bite.
[music playing]
The team reviews the footage,
looking for the telltale muscle
spasm that signals that the
electrical current affected
the shark.
Oh, did you see that?
Oh, you can
actually literally see
the pectoral fin flicking down.
Yeah.
NARRATOR: It's a
subtle movement,
but the slight flick of
the shark's pectoral fin
tells the research team the
deterrent seems to work.
That first flexing
of the pectoral fin,
that's a standard reaction
to an electric field
that we've seen in the past.
Yeah.
We're in the really early
stages of this testing.
But if we get more really good
trials like we've had today,
then we'll get a clearer
understanding of how effective
this deterrent actually is.
[music playing]